the justice department promises sweeping
changes to Louisville's Police
Department after a federal investigation
found its officers have routinely
discriminated against black people and
violated their constitutional rights the
doj opened this investigation nearly two
years ago after the 2020 shooting death
of Brianna Taylor while police were
executing a no-nock warrant officers
killed the 26 year old woman after her
boyfriend fired a gunshot Jeffrey gaze
is at the justice department in
Washington he's got more on this story
Jeff these details are very troubling
this is a scathing
outlines unlawful conduct by the
Louisville Police Department and really
a culture of racist Behavior this is a
report that was started after the death
of Brianna Taylor but one city leader
told the Department of Justice that it's
really just a symptom of problems in the
city
this conduct is unacceptable
it is heartbreaking attorney general
Merritt Garland called The Justice
Department's findings and affront to the
people of Louisville the doj report
concluded that Louisville officers
routinely use Force disproportionate to
the threat or resistance post
unnecessarily using neck restraints
police canines and tasers often without
facing consequences some have videotaped
themselves throwing drinks at
pedestrians from their cars insulted
people with disabilities and called
black people monkeys animal and boy the
report found officers discriminate
against black people searching them more
than twice as often as white drivers at
traffic stops it also set a significant
number of search warrant applications
failed to establish probable cause with
more than 60 percent of no knock
warrants and forced entries into
buildings carried out against black
people
in the case of Brianna Taylor's 2020
death police were executing a no-knock
warrant that one officer has since
admitted contain falsified information
months later the city passed legislation
it called Brianna's law Banning no knock
warrants I don't even know what to think
Tamika Palmer is Taylor's mother it's
heartbreaking to know that everything
you've been seeing from day one has to
be said again
thank you
according to the report police
misconduct also spread to the
demonstrations that followed Taylor's
death claiming Louisville officers use
Force against peaceful protesters
without adequate justifications attacked
protesters who had already surrendered
and made mass arrest without probable
cause Louisville mayor Craig Greenberg
to those people who've been harmed on
behalf of our city government
I'm sorry
you deserved better
we can and will do better
the doj investigation in Louisville is
just one of nine open investigations by
the Department of Justice and by the
Biden Administration now just to
highlight a few there is the
investigation in Minneapolis Post The
Death of George Floyd but also now an
investigation in Memphis Tennessee where
Tyree Nichols died in police custody two
months ago Yale
all right Jeff begaze thank you as we
said this is very troubling I'd like to
know what can and will do better now
means yeah and to hear that it's a
culture of racist behavior in 2023 is
not only troubling and sad but it also
makes you very angry when you're in
Louisville people when we were there
were telling us these stories yeah it's
very sad now to see that it's officially
now known and out in the open it's very
depressing and the mayor also said uh
that it's betrayal of the
professionalism of the cops they have
that are doing their jobs and doing them
well and you know they're going to make
changes they got to recruit new people
in and they need good people I hope they
can find them essentially the report is
saying to Serve and Protect but not if
you're black says Jeff thank you again